nobody knows why the targaryens first
came to the island of dragonstone
old valyria was then at the height of
its power in the center of the civilized
world
which ended at the narrow sea westeros
was a filthy backwater with seven
kings squabbling over borders and minor
glories
so much for progress the island itself
was
and is nothing it had no gold or
gems to lure valyrian nobility
all it has is rock mostly a shiny black
stone
too brittle for war and too sharp for
building
the targaryens called it dragonglass
i call it useless but the targaryens
managed to raise a castle here
simpletons claim they used ancient
valyrian sorcery forgetting that the
targaryens brought a small army with
them from essos
there's no magic in strong backs though
admittedly the castle is unlike any in
westeros
foreign and strange
if the targaryens ever regretted their
baron outpost and longed for the
comforts of home
the doom made their folly permanent
valyria collapsed into the waves and was
no more
to look east was to see the ruin of
their homeland
the greatest civilization before or
since
but to look west as aegon realized
was to see a fertile land ripe for
conquest
perhaps even a new valyria
though good for little else dragonstone
was the perfect staging point for
aegon's invasion of westeros
the blackwater bay granted easy access
to the continent
the lands there were disputed by three
kingdoms
the reach the iron islands and the
stormlands
but their capitals were far enough away
that none could mount a force before
aegon got a foothold
even if their kings had been able to
stop bickering over whose problem he was
then it was too late aegon had chosen
his first
camp well with the bay to the east
the river to the south and open fields
to the north and west
his army would be impossible to take by
surprise
a perfect site for an invasion and one
day
his capital city king's landing
aegon targaryen landed to our south and
as had many before him liked the look of
the riverlands
my ancestor edmund tully led the
desertion of riverlords to his cause
and was rewarded by getting to watch
king harren burn in his own tower
on the shores of the god's eye due north
of the isle of faces
rises a monument to arrogance and
cruelty
harrenhal for a people who prided
themselves on their ships
the iron man of old seized any chance to
leave them
and carved out a vast kingdom from the
peaceful riverlords
the empire reached its zenith under king
heron
horror called the black by those he
terrorized
and by his own men though they meant it
proudly
king heron enslaved the riverlands to
raise the mightiest fortress
westeros had ever seen a castle that
could garrison a million men
with walls so vast that winters would
come and go
and besieging armies grow old and gray
before the castle fell
five towers he ordered reaching into the
heavens like
grasping fingers a monstrosity
which he forced our people to build for
their own
subjugation but the very day the slaves
laid the last stone
aegon targaryen and his sisters arrived
in the south
when they arrived with their small army
heron
laughed and shut the gates harrenhal
would have its first test
and an easy one at that
it failed herron hall could have
withstood an assault from
all the armies in westeros combined but
heron learned that the tallest and
thickest walls meant little
to dragons for dragons fly
the problem with huge castles as they
blind you to what's outside
both by their size and the arrogance
they inspire
not that the ironborn ever lacked for
that
they take pride in their ignorance of
every trapping of civilization
though any baker could have told them
that fire turned stone
walls into an oven and so
harren the black finally lived up to his
name
and the river lord swept the ironborn
back to the sea
when aegon the conqueror came to the
iron islands the priest king lodos
claimed his divine
father the ironborn's drowned god had
shown him krakens pulling aegon's ships
into the deep
no kraken's ever arrived and even if
they had they wouldn't have stopped
hagen and his dragon without wings of
their own
confused lodus filled his pockets with
stones and walked into the sea
to take counsel with his father
thousands followed him
but apparently the drowned god didn't
appreciate a crowd
their corpses washed upon the iron
islands for years
when aegon targaryen declared that
westeros was now his
king mern the ninth allied with king
lauren lannister of the westerlands
together they fought to save westeros
from another
foreign barbarian whose family practices
were decent men to shame
but the dragons won and the field of
fire claimed mirn and all his sons
grandsons and brothers
instead of using the castle for what it
was built to do
harlan tyrell surrendered it to aegon
without a fight
in exchange harlan was given the castle
his family had served for
thousands of years with all its
attendant lands and lords
for over a thousand years the green
hand's sons and grandsons ruled the
reach as house gardener
the offshoots of his daughters grew into
vast and powerful houses
in their own right except for house
tyrell
we chose instead to serve our gardener
cousins faithfully as stewards
to manage their stronghold of highgarden
and the daily affairs of the reach
our words are growing strong
and under our stewardship the reach did
just that
as did we until a blundering king almost
cost us
everything aegon targaryen had landed in
westeros
king murn allied us with the roth to
repel the upstarts army one can only
marvel that king mirn did not reconsider
when he saw the living dragons against
him
perhaps he should have sought counsel
from his trusted stewards before he set
out
then again perhaps he did
at the field of fire aegon and let us
not forget
his sisters burnt the combined armies of
the reach and rock
king mirn paid for his misjudgment with
his life and that of his ancient family
in a day the reach had lost its king its
ruling house
and most of its army thankfully for
everyone
my ancestor harlan terrell had better
sense
until the maesters sorted out the intel
among mern's cousins
harlan the steward was acting lord of
highgarden
to ensure peace and life in the reach he
would yield the castle to aegon
the other castles and families would
then follow as they had
since the dawn age aegon had a continent
to conquer
and the fertile reach was too valuable
to raise
he accepted harlan's proposal and
welcomed our lands into his kingdom
to show his gratitude aegon entitled
harlan to highgarden
the castle his family had served for a
thousand years
and made house terrell his wardens of
the south
choosing us over older greater families
in the reach
our house thus owed everything to the
targaryens
the lannisters reigned as kings of the
rock for thousands of years
and worked to make it the envy of the
rest of the seven kingdoms
our time as kings ended however when
aegon targaryen
otherwise known as aegon the conqueror
arrived in westeros with his army
the last king of the rock king loren
lannister
joined forces with king mern gardner the
king of the reach
together with sixty thousand men they
met the targaryen host in open battle
history tells us that aegon unleashed
all three of his dragons
slaughtering four thousand men at what
came to be known
as the field of fire king man himself
was burned alive that day
and house gardener turned to ash with
him
seeing both the threat and opportunity
the targaryens represented lauren
wisely surrendered and aided aegon in
his further conquest of westeros
the lannisters were thus appointed lords
paramount of the westerlands
and wardens of the west titles we hold
to this day while aegon burned the kings
of the iron islands the rock and the
reach
his fiercest commander and rumored
brother
or his baratheon set out to subdue the
stormlands no matter how fierce a
warrior he was
no one could have envied his task
storm's end had since thousands of years
of war and never fallen
but argilac the storm king chose not to
barricade himself behind its walls
and gave always the battle he must have
hoped for
oris slewed argilac and took argilac's
castle
kingdom daughter sigil and house words
house baratheon became the lord of the
stormlands
when aegon and his dragons landed on
westeros
the kings of the rock and the reach sent
all their men to die to defend their
grounds
tauren stark knelt to spare his people
the same fate
he placed duty above pride the south had
already fallen to aegon and his dragons
only the north remained my ancestor
king torrenstark marched the north down
to the trident and beheld aegon's army
larger than tauren's own by half and
with three dragons circling overhead
many northern bannermen wanted to attack
anyway claiming northern valor would
carry the day
others wanted to fall back to moat
kaelin and make a stand there
but tauren had heard how the armies of
the rock and the reach had burned on the
field of fire
and had seen the fires still glowing
beneath the rubble of harrenhal
he knelt and laid his ancient crown at
aegon's feet
and rose a king no more but lord of
winterfell and warden of the north
some northerners still sneer at my
ancestor as the king who knelt
forgetting that because of tauren
they're alive today to smear
their ancestors didn't leave their
burned bones at the trident and their
twisted swords didn't fill aegon's new
throne
no army in the seven kingdoms can match
the pride and chivalry of the
knights of the vale after all they were
the first
true knights in westeros until the
dragons changed the game
when aegon the conqueror landed in
westeros the queen regent of the vale
shut the bloody gate against the
targaryens and masked the knights of the
vale behind it
to lock it but forsenya simply flew her
dragon to a balcony of the erie where
the boy king was playing
and gave the boy a ride round the castle
in return for his mother's submission
when aegon the conqueror landed in
westeros
the high septon locked himself in a sept
for seven days
and seven nights finally the crone
lifted her golden lamp and showed him
the path ahead
the high septon himself would anoint and
crown aegon
as lord of the seven kingdoms and the
faith militant rallied behind aegon
in governing his newly united land
yet aegon and his sisters never wholly
accepted the faith
the high septon had conceded aegon's
marriages to his sisters
as a relic of his valyrian heritage
which would soon fade
aegon targaryen sought to unite westeros
as nymeria had dorne the other six
kingdoms fell quickly before his dragons
and ambition
when his sister wife rhaenys flew her
dragon south and demanded our surrender
as well
princess maria martel warned
i will not fight you nor will i kneel to
you
dorne has no king tell your brother that
rhaenys threatened that the next time
the targaryens would come with fire and
blood
maria replied you may burn us
my lady but you will not bend us
break us or make us bow
this is dorne you are not wanted here
return at your peril
rhaenys did and she died
her dragon died all her soldiers
died eventually her brother the
conqueror
conceded that what nymeria had done
he could not undo generations later
another foolish targaryen invaded dorne
he died as well eventually we did join
the seven kingdoms
but when we wanted and on our terms
you